buongiorno a tutti
dallo scorso dicembre
io vivo da sola e nel cercare di gestire
al meglio la mia vita con le varie
incombenze extradomestiche faccio quello
che fa la maggior parte della gente
comune
mi occupo della casa quindi esco a fare
la spesa la a boss tiro tengo in ordine
cucina solo che non lo faccia
usando le mie braccia e le mie gambe
bensì lo faccia usando le braccia e le
gambe di due assistenti
ad esempio l'altra sera dovevamo
preparare una cena per degli amici
allora chiamato il mio assistente a sit
com da scott di shopping siamo usciti
siamo andati a far la spesa
noi passiamo accanto agli scaffali
io gli dico quello che mi serve
lui lo prenderò mette nel carrello poi
andiamo alle casse io gli dico di
prendere il portafogli lui paga e poi mi
appendere borse della spesa alla
carrozzina
poi torniamo a casa siamo tornati a casa
c'era d'ordine
allora io ho preso un pan ha iniziato a
spolverare lui invece a rabat i
pavimenti
poi ho visto che c'erano degli indumenti
sopra il divano e allora gli ho chiesto
di riporli dentro l'armadio sono andata
con lui e spiegato dove volevo che
fossero riposti e poi siamo tornati in
cucina abbiamo iniziato a preparare una
cena io non ho molta autonomia in casa
però quelle poche cose che riesca a fare
sono mie e guai a chi me le trucca ad
esempio io il monopolio dell'accensione
del piano cottura ad induzione
allora
cucinare e io lì a presidiare il piano
cottura per tutto il tempo
poi abbiamo preparato il tavola nel
mezzo la tovaglia li ho scelti piatti
bicchieri poi sono arrivati i miei amici
e al sif è tornato nella sua camera per
riposare e noi siamo stati insieme
insieme agli amici
io oggi sono qui per parlarvi di vita
indipendente
vita indipendente ha una filosofia di
vita
significa poter vivere come chiunque
altro
nonostante la grave disabilità da cui si
aspetti
vivere in modo indipendente per una
persona che affetta da una grave
disabilità
significa poter fare tutte quelle cose
compiere quegli atti quotidiani che per
una persona comune sono normali per una
persona disabile invece spesso diventano
delle imprese titaniche
difficili
addirittura in molti casi impossibili da
compiere autonomamente
senza l'aiuto di qualcuno
ecco allora che entra in gioco il ruolo
dell'assistente personale
assistente personale è un individuo che
può avere una formazione professionale
ma non è detto che fa rabbia
fondamentalmente è una persona che aiuta
la persona disabile a compiere quelle
azioni che durante la giornata sono
indispensabili per vivere
perché vivere in modo indipendente per
una persona affetta da una grave
disabilità che sia essa motoria
sensoriale o psichica significa
essenzialmente
poter vivere per contro all'idea comune
di morti che invece credono che una
persona disabile debba accontentarsi di
sopravvivere
io vivo da sola grazie ad un progetto
che mi è stato attivato dalla regione
piemonte a partire dal 2003 e che si
chiama proprio vita indipendente
riprende quindi il nome del movimento
per la vita indipendente che nasce negli
stati uniti negli anni 60 quando un
gruppo di studenti dell'università di
berkeley rivendica il diritto di vivere
come tutti gli altri studenti quindi di
alloggiare nel campus anziché nello
spedale come erano soliti fare
rivendica questo diritto e lo ottiene
inizialmente sono gli stessi compagni di
corso a garantire loro la dovuta
assistenza
poi il movimento si trasforma in un vero
e proprio progetto e quindi gli studenti
disabili possano poi assumere personale
di assistenza
ecco allora che io faccio parte come ho
detto di questo progetto attualmente in
piemonte ci sono 200 progetti attivi
suddivisi tra i 54
consorzi socio assistenziali
abbiamo detto che è vita indipendente
essenzialmente una filosofia di vita è
proprio il diritto di vivere come
chiunque altro
nonostante la disabilità
vita indipendente
importante per due motivi
il primo
è che permette alla persona disabile di
poter vivere da sola di poter essere
libera di gestire la propria
indipendenza
la propria quotidianità e di poter anche
progettare il proprio futuro
per molto tempo
l'unica risposta che i servizi sociali
tavano alla richiesta d'aiuto della
persona disabile era
l'istituzionalizzazione
ossia il ricovero in strutture di
accoglienza in casa di cura
questo anche nel caso in cui la persona
disabile fosse molto giovane quindi
avesse di fronte un intera vita
con la vita indipendente invece la
persona disabile può vivere a casa
propria può decidere di arredare la casa
come meglio preferisce può decidere di
fare ciò che vuole può sentirsi libera
l'altro motivo è invece un motivo
essenzialmente economico
per l'istituzionalizzazione
sono necessari da 6 a 7 mila euro al
mese che vengono erogati attraverso un
mix di interventi da parte del comune
dei servizi socio assistenziali e della
sanità
un progetto di vita indipendente invece
necessita da 2 a 2.500 euro al mese
quindi noi notiamo come in realtà il
risparmio sia notevole e queste risorse
che vengono risparmiate possono essere
utilizzate per coprire degli altri
servizi
ecco allora che la vita indipendente si
traduce in un valido modello di welfare
perché in realtà non riguarda più
soltanto la persona disabile ma riguarda
tutti
anche coloro che probabilmente non
arriveranno mai direttamente non avranno
mai bisogno perché con le risorse che
vengono risparmiate grazie a questi
progetti si possono attivare o
proseguire altri servizi
io ora vi chiedo di fare una semplice
riflessione
immaginate questa sera di non poter fare
ritorno alle vostre abitazioni
immaginate di essere costretti ad andare
a vivere in una struttura di accoglienza
una casa di cura di quelle che
conosciamo tutti
ora ponetevi a una semplice domanda
quale valore attribuito alla vostra
libertà